la cave est super
performante
je m'appelle martin o'neill j'ai 21 ans
et il ma passion c'est la passion
ben je vous prépare mes affaires les
ciseaux des brosses donc aux sabots d'or
de loulo m'a déjà éclairé plaire aux
clientes
faut que ça donne envie aussi on veut
pas être une coiffeuse et être malgré
présenter des choses qu'elle a que
j'adorais faire ouais mais passer des
enfants arrivent à la raison que sa
petite cousine ou les enfants des
étrangers même c'étati elle est toujours
là va qu'une brosse dans les cheveux on
encourage voilà même que les jeunes ont
pas baissé les bras moi j'aime bien
m'occuper des gens qui viennent dans un
salon de coiffure et qui recherche du
bien-être auprès de la parfaite et c'est
mes cours de bp brevet professionnel
donc il me reste une année à faire avant
l'examen
donc bienvenue c'est ici que je
travaille je fais part mon bébé on était
à frotter à d'autres apprentis que ce
soit ces ape ou bp professionnels et
s'être volaille la mas pu faire gagner
ce concours c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident parce qu'au début dans la
coiffure et des fautes autant rester
debout c'est des horaires pas facile
donc moi je lui dis qu'il faut avancer
et il faut voir l'avant faux pas cette
année là on est jolie ces tensions les
extensions donc vous voulez plus de la
longue voilà qu'il faudrait dans tes
cheveux c'est essayer de rajouter un peu
de cuivre et elle arrive à
trouver des astuces pour tous qui dit
commerciale dans tout ce qui est dit
vente et puis l art est passé durant une
cliente dès son arrivée
l'avenir je vois prend de me projeter de
pouvoir me démarquer des zones jeunes
d'avoir beaucoup de connaissances et sur
qui me battre pour avoir ma place